we looked over the last week at an
incredible viral interview where Trump
lawyer Joe takapina went on MSNBC and
was interviewed by Ari melber and lunged
for papers tried to Lunge and take
papers from Ari melber's hand another
Trump lawyer has gone on MSNBC and it
went just as poorly if not worse instant
collapse from Drew findling Drew
findling is a criminal defense attorney
he's really known like as a hip-hop
attorney because he has represented a
number of well-known hip-hop musicians
doesn't make him any better or worse of
an attorney just it's an interesting
thing that Trump has gone with someone
who is known really as as a hip-hop
attorney
um he went on MSNBC Ari melber asked him
questions it really doesn't go well for
findling take a look at this same level
of passion but you're not the judge or
the jury in this case you're the lawyer
we're talking to you not for your
conclusions without evidence but for the
evidence you can Marshal right now I'm
giving you the time if you can't do it
tonight if you can't give us any
arguments then we will note that but let
me put up on the screen again for your
rebuttal if you want to take this time
and importantly I should mention this is
a defense attorney for Trump in the
Georgia case which I believe is
potentially the strongest one uh
election fraud in Georgia if you request
or attempt to cause another person to
engage in voter fraud that's criminal
solicitation if you conspire or agree
with another to commit a violation that
is another Georgia statute those are
both felonies those are just two and
there are as you know others Donald
Trump posts December 14. I'll give you
the widest possible birth that before
it's certified there are arguments that
could be theoretically made about
alternate electors but post December
14th he's on tape doing it we have a new
call we learned about in the last week
demanding it how is that not soliciting
or conspiring fraud
yeah so so are I'm familiar my team is
familiar with all those statutes and
while I'm looking at this you know
camera I can tell you we're incredibly
familiar with those statues they aren't
new to us we do a lot of political cases
sure we are absolutely confident having
looked at the evidence that our client
has not violated any of those we're not
going to look at it two-dimensionally
we're going to look at a
three-dimensional
and he's completely Innocent but what
did he mean when he said find votes that
don't exist after certification what
could that possibly mean other than find
votes that don't exist
well I will I will say this and that is
that again okay
looking at the entire
62 minutes putting it all in context
there was nothing illegal said by our
client Ah that's the best when Trump
said I need 11
000 votes give me a break I just want to
find 11
780 votes which is one more than we have
what did he mean when he said that well
you've got to listen to the whole call
in context oh really did he open the
call with everything I'm about to say is
merely a joke what what could have
preceded that that would have made that
in any way not a violation of those
statutes and discontinued and melbridge
is doing everything he can to try to
actually get substance from Drew
findling did he lost the election and
got people to submit false material to
the government and everywhere else or
conspire to do so and that's a potential
crime now it it's so so Ari let me tell
you because uh what I'm not going to do
is I'm not going to be a hypocrite and
I'm not going to be disingenuous oh good
well then I'm sure he's gonna that's a
nice disclaimer when I talk about
prosecutors who I know very very well
okay and and have great relationships
with but when I call and say and file
something that they that they went down
the political Avenue and that has no
place in this case I'm not going to turn
around and start being political because
then so understand that this is a case
where the fact this is this is a classic
particularly for lawyers on TV where
you're not you're not trying the case on
TV at least not overtly
um if if the facts aren't on your side
you argue about process it was political
and it was the wrong venue and it was
all targeting my client unfairly and
blah blah blah um a hypocrite for
everything that I put in 50 pages so
respectfully I appreciate you bringing
that up and I appreciate that you
appreciate it I do appreciate being on
the show but I got to tell you but I'm
not going political I gotta tell you I'm
not going I'm giving you time and I'll
give your colleagues time and we'll have
you back but it is not accurate
absolutely but this is a case about
trying to steal an election ascertaining
the facts of that is not quote unquote
political it is the bleeding the Beating
Heart of the center of this case because
Donald Trump lied about it and it seems
today that you're in a you have an
inability to acknowledge that he lost
the state of Georgia which is odd
because you know he lost the state of
Georgia we all know that
I don't have an inability to do anything
I have the ability to tell you what I
think was in the scope of the questions
that I'll answer regarding the filing of
50 pages motion and 400 pages of
exhibits and we've got concerns I think
you'd agree we covered in a special
purpose grand jury nothing right
understood and but nothing in that
is political from our vantage point in
fact we call out he's not going to do
anything political at all in terms of
answering inconvenient questions but
then when they stuff this filing full of
400 pages of quote concerns that are
riddled with political concerns that's
not political according to him if you're
having trouble following this I don't
blame you for being political so I'm not
going to be disingenuous and start being
political I'm going to talk about the
facts that are contained in there yeah
right and I'm not going to be put in a
position where I have to make one claim
or another claim
um I am as you know you pointed out my
relationship to the bar deeply committed
to my profession and deeply committed
all right yeah so now he's saying he
really is committed to being a lawyer
wow you know I thought that Trump would
I really thought they had Trump dead to
rights by the way the look on Ari
melber's face here in this still shot
kind of says everything says it says it
all
um I I Trump seems like he's super
guilty he seems guilty as hell but did
you know his lawyer is really committed
to the practice of law oh he is oh well
then it must be not guilty I guess this
is a nonsense interview and I don't
really even know whether so I guess
MSNBC wants to do these interviews
because they sort of always go like this
and it's very cartoonish I guess the
lawyers want to do the interviews
because they know probably that Trump
doesn't always pay his lawyers and so if
they can get some publicity out of it
then maybe they can make money on the
back end from other people hiring them I
don't really know but they come together
and it just instantly implodes and so
the continued interviews with Trump
Trump's lawyers not going particularly
well and then closing out our review of
the last 24 hours it also not going
particularly well for Donald Trump one
of our sponsors is zipx nicotine
toothpicks don't you think it's time you
stopped putting smoke and vape oils in
your lungs zippix toothpicks are
convenient way to curb the nicotine
Cravings zippix toothpicks are super
discreet you can use them anytime
anywhere smoking and vaping aren't
allowed including flights sporting
events in restaurants they're available
in six different flavors with options of
two and three milligrams of nicotine if
you're not a nicotine user zipix also
offers caffeine and b12 infused
toothpicks zipx has already helped tens
of thousands of customers ditch the
cigarettes ditch the Vapes they might be
able to help you too if you're a smoker
or a vapor give zipx toothpicks a try
your lungs will thank you go to
zipxtoothpix.com today save 10 percent
with the code pacman10 at checkout just
remember you must be 21 or older to
order the link is down below